johnny-boy check the window
yeah then okay hold your position no you
haven't moved
Garret me and the boys are one match
away from hitting generation seven I've
got 60 seconds until I get my Titan back
I cannot die so you stayed up all night
gaming in the hope that our neighbor and
his teenage buddies will think that
you're cool yeah bro it totally worked
GD underscore Alfredo asked me to send
him a Spotify playlist of my favorite
summer jams dare he is asking me Quinn
for music Rex question have you seen my
Tom Brown box from it and I already know
the first track in the playlist clams
Casino
I'm their guy Oxford cloth pearl buttons
signature grosgrain details whoa sniped
seriously broke one retweet from
somebody like GD underscore and I'm on
the map as a tastemaker but my life
could like change forever gear I have my
big meeting downtown with Lewis in half
an hour oh my god I totally forgot it
big deal and I had this burn card sick
Quinn this is a no stop talking my Tom
Brown boxers are lucky not yet Yanni boy
stay on my flank Quinn you're in way too
deep right the coolest thing about GD
underscore Alfredo is that he's got like
so much mystique around him because
nobody knows what the underscore stays
just pause for one second so we can talk
about where they might be and get murked
and let my teammates down
boobies guy 93 has not left the house in
two months oh no I feel so sad for him
it is sad GERD he lost both his legs oh
[ __ ]
is he is Ian like a children's house
when I crushed his body with my Titan
hahaha
oh yeah and your face boobies got you
getting massacred out there bro Oh
massacred okay you know what
Xbox sign up no no no close stop
listening stop listening what are you
doing yes Johnny boy I am fine we're
good
it was just Garrett yeah no I know I I
hate him too Xbox shut off no no Johnny
boy how dare you Garrett you just ruined
an entire night of hard work by some of
the most influential teenagers on the
internet right now well in real people
life I have a meeting and my job and I
need my lucky Tom Brown are we dead
we're getting an HJ right now uh-oh
see now you did it now you did again you
just set it off one match away and you
shark the bed I thought we were a team
Quinn Jonnie boy it wasn't me it was gay
are you kidding me Garrett you do this
to me on the day of my chem test it's
the middle of July yeah summer school I
developmental issues you clown we do
wait are you wearing my boxers okay good
news is found your boxers why are you
wearing my boxers I think you guys stuff
all the time
you never lock your apartment idiots
wait are you not locking the door when
you leave uh
no definitely not I lost my key some
time last year plus I kind of like the
idea of people being able to just like
Busta and Kramer style you know dude
what the hell Yanni boy you were so
Kramer ring right now I love it
these are pathetic I'm texting GD
Alfredo do you not pronounce the
underscore ring we're booting you from
the Clare what no do not do this to me
you know that I need this take my boxers
off you little freak I heard you on
Quinn's mic talking about how lucky they
are you think I'm gonna take them off
later idiots are you happy Gary you just
got us rodeoed he just climbed up on
your head and and ripped off the circuit
panel Jesus think you'd still both Bears
my Tom Brown boxers unbelieving uh
actually no he just took one pair I'm
wearing the distract ones bro these are
super comfy you should you should buy
more sup guys
one of the best snipers around is
looking for a new clan to roll with so
definitely subscribe to the channel if
you guys need a new team member I'll hit
you up